Welcome to our project
Google Developers Hackademy,
where Spanish-speaking experts
from Latin America
will show you
some of our tools,
developer’s products,
APIs and new tricks.
This course is divided
into five parts.
We invite you to watch it
and learn along.
Let's start.
Hello. Welcome to the HTML5
web develop
introduction course
with Google Drive.
My name is
Cesar Anton Dorantes,
Google Developer Expert
for the Google Drive platform.
In this lesson we will see
the following subjects:
HTML5 document structure;
document structure
in HTML5 applications;
free web hosting using
Google Drive Public Folders;
automatic synchronization
with Google Drive;
and, finally,
a practice in which we'll
build an HTML5 website.
Are you ready?
Let's get it started!
HTML5 DOCUMENT STRUCTURE
HTML5 presents
a different approach
than the previous versions.
Now it emphasizes
on maintaining
a clear and simple structure.
Today we use HTML mainly
to describe the order
and structure of our app.
The logic,
written in JavaScript,
and the visual details,
written in CSS,
are kept apart
and we'll talk about them
in a lesson later on.
HTML5 has
a very semantic structure
and its labels
are very descriptive,
which makes it easy for us
to declare and to edit
the structure
of our application.
If you're familiarized
with HTML4,
you'll notice that everything
is much easier now.
We start by declaring
the doctype,
with has been shortened,
making it easier to write
and remember,
since now you just need to
mention it's an HTML document.
Now we put the HTML labels.
These indicate where our code
starts and where it ends.
Here we also declare what
language the document is in
by using the "lang" attribute
and the corresponding
language code.
In this case we use
the "es" code,
since the document
is in Spanish.
In this part we declare
the "head" and "body" tags.
In "head" we place
the information we wish
is only available for browsers
and search engines.
In "body" we place
the information we wish
the user can see
through the browser.
Time to write the title
we wish to be shown
on the browser
for our application.
To do so, we write the title
within the "title" tag,
inside "head."
Now let's place
some metatags to declare
our page's basic information.
We start with
our page's encoding
inside the "charset" attribute.
UTF-8 is recommended
because it accepts accents
and letter "ñ."
By using the "name"
y "content" attributes
we declare our page's
description and author.
You can see I'm not using
the famous "keywords."
Nowadays its use
is no longer recommended,
because browsers don't
take them into account
for the site's ranking anymore,
and sometimes they can
even harm it.
Time to start declaring
the content we wish
to be shown in our application.
Remember that in HTML5
this is done inside
the "body" tag.
It is recommended
that our page's main content
is indicated
inside the "article" tag.
Let's write it in our code.
Finally, let's place the content
we want to show inside "article"
and that's it! We already have
an HTML5 app
with all basic elements.
It's very important
to keep the files
in separate folders
according to their type.
This will be very useful through
our project's development,
because it makes it easy
to find them and edit them.
As well as declaring the routes
to the different files
from the code,
particularly when we're
working on big projects.
The basic folders
for an HTML5 project are:
"CSS:"
This is where we store
the files that determine
the appearance
and visual effects.
"HTML:"
In this folder we put
the corresponding files
to each page of our project.
"IMG:"
This is where we keep
textures, photographs,
logos and other images
we will use.
It's very useful to coordinate
from the start
with the Design team
on image names,
this way they can add
or update elements
without having to wait
for the Development team.
"JS:"
This is where
JavaScript files go,
which we will use to define
our application's behavior.
The index.html file
must always be placed
in the root directory,
apart from the rest of
HTML files in our project.
In this file we put
the welcoming page.
This file structure
is the same for pages
or web applications.
Now that we have
all the files
our project requires,
it is ready
for the future of apps,
which are HTML5
Packaged Apps.
The main difference is
that a Packaged App
contains a file
in the root directory
called "Manifest,"
and the user, instead
of downloading the data
from the server each time,
it is installed in the computer
as a regular app.
It can even access the hardware
connected directly through USB,
as with native applications.
Nowadays we can find
this technology
already in use in Windows 8,
BlackBerry 10
and the new Firefox OS,
but it will very soon
be available
in the Chrome Packaged Apps,
which will allow you to sell
your HTML5 apps
from Chrome Store,
which can be installed
in any device
containing Google Chrome.
FREE WEB HOSTING
USING PUBLIC FOLDERS
A very powerful tool
from Google Drive
for developers
is the option of using
folders as hosting
for both pages
and HTML5 apps for free
and with no broadband
limitations.
Nowadays, Google Drive
allows us to store up to 15 GB
for free
and has several
very economic packages
to rent additional space
if we need to.
For those who own
a Chrome Book,
Google gives them 100 GB
of storing in Drive
for one year.
In order to use a folder
as web hosting,
just follow this easy steps.
Step 1:
Frist, we need to create
the folder we will use
to store our project
from Google Drive's
web application.
For this example we'll create
a folder called
"Drive HTML hosting."
Step 2:
Now, we select the folder
we just created
by right-clicking
with our mouse.
We look for the option "Share"
and we select "Share."
Step 3:
You'll notice a window
will appear
in which the sharing options
for this folder
are shown.
In this case, we need
to find the section
"Who has access."
By default, folders are private.
In order to activate
the hosting,
we need to turn the folder
into a public one.
For that we first need
to click on "Change."
Step 4:
The window "Sharing options"
will pop up.
In "Visibility options,"
we need to select the options
"Public in the Web"
and click on "Save."
This will send us back
to the previous display.
Now we'll see the contents
of the folder
are marked as
"Public in the Web."
And that's it!,
We have now activated
"Drive HTML hosting"
for all files and subfolders
we store in this folder.
Let's click on "End"
to exit this display.
Step 5:
Now, we need to know the URL
that was assigned
to our folder.
In order to see it,
we right-click on the folder,
but this time we pick
the option "Details."
If we did it correctly,
we will see a new detail
has been added:
"Storing."
This address leads
to our folder
but in a web page format.
If the folder contains
a file named index.html,
it will load it by default
when someone access it.
Otherwise,
it will show a list
with all the files
contained in this folder,
so we can also use it
to easily share
all its contents with the world.
If it is a file Google Drive
can use,
it will show its contents
directly in the browser.
Otherwise,
a download of the
selected file will start.
To profit from the benefits
of automatic synch,
the first thing we got to do
is download the app
"Google Drive for Desktop,"
which is available
for Mac and Windows.
Once installed, we need to wait
for the synch of the files
in my unit to finish.
The time it'll take
will depend on the size
and on the amount of files,
as well as on the speed
of our Internet connection.
This will allow us to create
and edit files
directly in our computer,
which will keep synchronized
with the cloud,
therefore, every time
we save a change,
and this will be automatically
and almost instantly shown
in our page or application.
Another great advantage
is that Google Drive
allows us to share folders
with other users,
which will keep synchronized
with their computers too,
as long as they have
the Google Drive for Desktop
app installed.
This facilitates teamwork
immensely.
This is one of the most powerful
real-time collaboration tools
the Google Drive platform
has to offer.
I invite you to watch
this lesson again,
this time pausing it
to follow the steps
and copy the code
that is shown.
If you want to compare,
you can see an example
on the website
that is shown on screen.
That will be all for now.
See you next lesson:
"Introduction to Google Charts,"
in which we'll learn,
among other things,
how to do charts
for your HTML5 apps,
and believe me,
you don't want to miss it.
I say goodbye for now, guys,
and remember:
keep on programming!